[Music]
we're 300 years of the coast of Santa's
little island and we're lighting an area
to attract plankton modulus feed on
plankton hopefully they'll come close to
us and we'll be able to swim with them
first
plankton come the mullahs appear
these Devil Rays have been
20 million years but divers like us are
recent as future visitors are summoned
to the feeding frenzy and this sanctuary
is threatened what can we do for a world
worth protecting National Geographic and
Rolex are sending me across Baja
California to explore the way wildlife
tourism is evolving in one of the most
biodiverse regions on the planet my
first stop is cabo pulmo I'm here to
meet David Castro whose family was
instrumental in transforming a small
fishing village into a global model of
sustainability the first years it was
very critical to bring people to start
doing the the ecotourism activities so
it's not an easy job just to try to to
create an MPA and then do it from zero
in the 90s overfishing had decimated
cabo pulmo sea life the reefer sick and
the local economy faltered my daddy
tells me how they suffer sometimes they
don't got a single fish the Castro's and
their neighbours took a chance they made
a pact to stop fishing and bet on
tourism instead
today Dobby was taking me on a dive with
bull sharks to show me how well cabo
pulmo smearin population has recovered
since it became a nationally protected
area
so we're 500 meters away from the coast
and there's probably like temple sharks
underneath us right now and we are the
crazy people that are gonna go under and
dive with them I'm super excited I won't
lie I'm a little scared but I think
that's no look the first time I made a
dive who was sharks
[Music]
as we dive we come across a school of
jacks swirling like an underwater
tornado that we've suspended in space is
wrapped and swallowed
[Music]
from afar they are a humbling force of
nature up close a wall of drifting eyes
this is what a healthy reef looks like
I almost forget why we're here
[Music]
and then the Sharks come
sharks have a negative reputation but
seeing them up close changes everything
fear gives way to reverence and
reverence transforms into the desire to
protect right now carefully lift rolling
by eco-tourism
the community push yourself to change
the the weight of make a living
people who really want to to have these
conservation adventure they come here
tourism is kind of the blood flow that
allows about how I try to help people
from other places in the world that they
can do the same thing we feel that we
are warriors for the ocean our dream is
to go in in the whole country of Mexico
just sharing the same knowledge that we
have full moon managed to build a
blueprint of sustainability the
community is eager to share with a world
my next stop is the island of Espiritu
Santo a neighboring wildlife hotspot
located in the Sea of Cortez emotional
complications will our espírito Santo de
sipan
division aqui if they're part either a
national sanctuary and UNESCO protected
park this cluster of small islands was
almost developed into a casino resort
until locals petitioned the government
for protection since it was declared a
national a protected area in 1995 small
tour boats have been taking adventurous
travelers to explore what many
considered to be the world's richest
outdoor thing about this so we are not
allowed to animals but this one's
commenting like
didn't cut you and all that baby ready
yeah
while most tourists Merkel was sealions
we decide to dive
we swim towards the massive rock
formations jutting from the ocean floor
between the towers of red rock sea lions
play in a cave they are fast and agile
and although they gently by her hands
and scuba suits it's not easy to keep
their attention a neutral group arrives
then another and another
suddenly dozens of tourists invade the
surface above us blocking the sunlight
and the sea lions scatter guides call
this the red wave red the colour of
their life vests
I wonder if activities like these are
blurring the line between natural
sanctuary and amusement park
[Music]
I'm on my way to La Paz Bay to explore
bajas most established wildlife
adventure the way tourism has evolved
here may serve as an example for newer
activities a meeting Danny Ramirez La
Paz for most whale shark expert and
conservationist her work has been
instrumental in ensuring tourism isn't
harming the whale shark the idea will be
to place our cameras on the northern sea
field to see the behavior of the charr
how they behave your change with
pressure
of people
Danny takes volunteers on her research
missions by including visitors she hopes
to forge a stronger balance between
tourism and conservation whale sharks
are migratory and collect by the
hundreds here when the waters are warm
and rich with nutrients they filters
thousands of gallons of water through
their gills to capture the massive
blooms of plankton they need to sustain
their diet the camera she places on its
fin will yield intimate footage from the
whale shark's point of view
[Music]
the goal is to see how the Sharks
behavior changes in the presence of
people and boats
[Music]
without web research we'll learn every
year the same animal returns around 60%
so this is at a special place for them
it's important for them so the idea of
idea I need to share this type of
information we train every year in
collaboration with the government to the
captain's to the guys they know how to
interact with the world sharks and I
really think that the tourism could be a
key they are part of the conservation of
the world shark and a reality in
traveling through Baja I've seen the
impact of wildlife tourism it can
transform a local economy and help
sustain a natural habitat
to find that balance we must blur the
line between local visitor and
conservationist
[Music]
you